iran a land of contradictions
i am outside of the city of yazed right
now
out in the desert and i just felt like i
needed to get away from
city life
the grits of the dust and the exhaust
the loudness of the horns
away from conversations and people
so today i'm out here which is quite
spectacular
great country fantastic place
uh the base or the foundation it has to
be the people
because these people are
very open
very hospitable
humbling cool
well educated actually a lot of them are
pretty well educated and in tune
with a lot of the world
made quite a few friends in a short time
it's one of those places where
you just show up
on a random street or in a park and
someone's going to come up to you and
talk to you
and want to hang out with you
and when you're traveling alone
it's sort of
the best thing that can happen right
because you're
in a culture and getting
the best understanding through the
people and what they have to say
people speak good english here
um
what else can i say it's a land of
contradictions right so
you have parts of tehran where
the very wealthy are walking around with
bandages on their nose is showing that
they've
just performed a nose job
which is a bit of a status symbol
there are huge drug issues here
uh the second night in tehran i
the guys i was staying with took me down
to this volunteering event
where we gave food
to heroin users
what else
cool stuff like
okay so facebook is
is outlawed right and it's blocked on
the internet a lot of stuff's blocked
youtube facebook some other stuff
but you can openly go to a phone store
ask for a vpn
which allows you to
search whatever you want on the internet
and pay for it in the open get a receipt
and go on with your life
so a lot of the things that are illegal
here
are not enforced at all
and i've been told numerous times it's
because
if they actually want to enforce that
law
at least half the population would be in
prison
which is
uh not
possible so
a lot of this stuff
is on the books
in theory but not in reality
so i'm constantly running into things
that are quite confusing here
like a vpn
like the fact that
the wealthy here here from what i've
been told they're quite
um
promiscuous in their sexual behavior
a lot of infidelity
and one girl even told me that if you
want to get some action
put a ring on your finger and you're way
more attractive and have more of a
likelihood to meet another person which
i thought was quite funny
um
people are less
brainwashed here on the whole
than in the states
yeah crazy to
it's crazy um claim but it's true it's
like
they know the [ __ ] they're being fed
and
they think the opposite
whereas at home i feel like
many people don't know that they're
being fed a ton of [ __ ]
now the [ __ ] comes at different
levels obviously
but
the very reason that or the fact that
most people i know told me
be safe in iran you might be beheaded
it's a dangerous place blah blah blah
we're completely off this is one of the
safest countries i've been to
if not the safest actually virtually
no violent crime exists on the streets
it's very stable
we're all targets as westerners walking
around with a load of cash hundreds and
hundreds of dollars or thousands in my
case right now
and
everyone knows that because foreigners
can't bank here
but we're not like immediate
targets where i can think of most parts
of the world like if you got off the
plane
in argentina and you're in buenos aires
and you stood out as a foreigner
and the locals knew you had thousands of
dollars on you
most likely you'd be robbed not here
very interesting
also
religion
the country seems really divided as far
as religion goes
the middle class upper class or the
higher
more highly educated people
don't seem to be very religious at all
and
seems to be quite a secular country in
many respects countryside's a bit
different
but i'd say at least half the population
is not following the book that closely
i could go on and on i'm going to be
writing tonight
i'm working on the blog internet
connections have been
quite a bit of a drag
so that's it for now
and i'm going to enjoy some peace and
quiet out here in this beautiful
desert all alone